it's been 13 years since Usher descended
from the sky to perform his hit OMG
during the Super Bowl 45 halftime show
in Arlington
Texas now the 45-year-old R&B star will
headline the Super Bowl 58 halftime show
in Las
Vegas the king of R&B found out he would
be performing on a phone call from Jay-Z
whose Rock Nation has served as the live
music entertainment strategists for the
NFL since
2019 it's no surprise he was part of
Rock selection process whose halftime
acts have promoted diverse current
artists with some connection to the host
City in which the game is played Super
Bowl 58's location at allean stadium in
Las Vegas is home to both of his soldout
residencies one in 2021 at Caesar's
Palace followed by an even bigger show
at Park
MGM Usher has become one of the most
popular acts in Sin City over the past 2
years Usher's original 14 Show run at
Caesars grossed more than $12.9 million
in ticket sales and as of last September
billboard reported that The mayway
Residency had sold 290,000 tickets
grossing $64 million across 59
shows while the NFL and apple music
cover the cost of the production which
can stretch to more than $10 million
some artists in recent years have chosen
to invest their own money the weekend
reportedly spent $7 million in 2021 to
Stage his performance performance and Dr
Dre spent the same amount the following
year to ensure the show fit his
vision however no one including Usher is
paid for their Super Bowl halftime
performance but the arrangement pays off
in other ways for Super Bowl Talent last
year's game garnered 115 million viewers
according to neelen making it one of the
most watched telecasts in US
history the potential marketing value of
a halftime performance is astronomical
considering the going rate for a single
307 second commercial during this year's
telecast is around $7
million Rihanna last year's Super Bowl
Halftime performer saw her digital song
sales increase by 390 according to
luminate the billionaire pop singer also
snuck in a midow plug for her fendy
beauty brand which led to more than $44
million in earned
media plus she pulled off the most epic
pregnancy announcement in recent pop
culture history similarly Usher is using
his superow performance to jumpstart a
robust plan for 2024 beginning with
releasing a new album on the day of the
game coming home this is his ninth
studio album and first since
2016 he also has licensing agreements
for a fragrance line and conac brand
Remy Martin which could see meaningful
sales bumps following the big
game this year's Super Bowl has a unique
marketing angle Taylor Swift's presence
cheering on her boyfriend Chief's tight
end Travis Kelce has been enough to
convince Health and Beauty Brands to buy
valuable commercial time Dove for
instance is doing its first Super Bowl
commercial in 18 years and Elf Cosmetics
is doing its first
ever Usher has promised to walk fans
through his 30-year music catalogue he
has hinted that he will be adapting
elements of his Vegas residency show
perhaps even the roller skating into his
performance and while performing for a
crowd of 65,000 in an NFL stadium is
drastically different than 5 000 in the
theater Usher recently told Vogue that
the show will feel like a personal
serenade to everyone watching I'm
literally speaking to every woman he
said I want to make it feel like
[Music]
that